jetzt haben wir aber anstatt Pauline
noch Richard David Precht der stört
nämlich susanne Gaschke
Unfall dass diese Frau aus Ministerin
geworden ist ja also ich nehme an dass
die hätte noch normal am normalen
Bedingungen im Auswärtigen Amt nicht
mein Praktikum gekriegt dass jemand mit
so diesem moralischen Inbrunst einer
Klassensprecherin einer Weltmacht einer
Kulturnation versucht zu erklären was
westliche Werte sind sie als systemische
Rivalen definiert und quasi ein
eskalationsszenario an die Wand malt
eine Werte geleitete Außenpolitik die
Wirklichkeit eine konfrontations
geleitete Außenpolitik ist
warum ja wir sind da eigentlich zwei
Sachen dran aufgefallen also das erste
war natürlich wirklich diese
unglaubliche Verachtung mit der dieser
Mann über die amtierende Außenministerin
spricht und da dachte ich das ist doch
eben so also völlig Diesseits noch all
dieser Wolken
Regeln wie wir jetzt nicht mehr sprechen
dürfen und wen wer wie nicht
diskriminieren dürfen und wenn wir
wohnen das ist so ganz solide
Frauenfeindlichkeit und und Herablassung
also von Typen von Typen immer noch gibt
die sich vermutlich selbst ja für
aufgeklärt halten ich nehme an das hat
recht dass das vermutlich tut so also
das fand ich schon ganz schön ganz schön
bemerkenswert also es ist Element von
von Herablassung darin und das zweite
ist natürlich ein allgemeinerer Punkt
und den finde ich schon sehr
besorgniserregend nicht nur in Bezug auf
China sondern eben auch im Bezug auf
Russland und den Ukraine Krieg ähm
dieses also zu sagen also werde also
geleitet der Außenpolitik ist ist ein
Mischung wir dürfen sozusagen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen eben gerade
Ländern wie China nicht vorhalten ich
würde sagen die Hongkong Chinesen oder
die Menschen in Tai waren die machen
sich schon ganz fundamentale Gedanken um
ihre Menschenrechte oder die Uiguren
oder überhaupt politische Opposition
dort genauso in Russland selbst ist ja
die die Opposition praktisch praktischen
mundtot gemacht also wer wer wer da
anderer Meinung ist als Putin ist im
Gefängnis oder im Ausland und das alles
kommt dann so daher also auch Männer die
sehr viel mehr geschätzt habe als als
ein recht also zum Helmut Schmidt haben
ist ein bisschen ähnlich immer vertreten
also wir sollen uns doch hier um unsere
wirtschaftlichen Dinge kümmern und nicht
einmischen irgendwie fremdkulturell dann
in die chinesische Kultur und dann sind
doch alle wirtschaftlich glücklich ich
finde dass man das also in einer derart
vernetzten Welt nicht mehr machen kann
dass man überlegen muss mit wem man
Geschäfte macht und welche Art von
Geschäften dass wir auch bei China eben
sehr viel vorsichtiger sein müssen als
wir es jahrelang waren und viel
vorsichtiger als gegenüber Russland wo
wir uns ja also willentlich und und und
ohne also ohne fundamentale not in eine
gasabhängigkeit z.B gegeben haben als
Mann längst wusste wie die in der
Ukraine reagieren
also was was agieren was sie da tun also
nach 2014 hat also jeder
Wirtschaftsminister noch mitgewirkt an
der Übergabe der Gasspeicher an an an
Gazprom an den Verkauf Irrsinn aber das
bedeutet Sie haben eine andere mein Herz
Brecht eine Unterhaltung aber finden Sie
den Landwirte eingreifen müssen also wie
weit geht ihre Kritik da darf ich das
nicht sagen wunderbar also deswegen
sitzen wir hier und oder deswegen hauen
wir uns darüber das ist ja das Schöne an
eine Demokratie da kommt niemand für ins
Gefängnis
vielleicht viel Gegenwind auf Twitter
aber das kann man ja wenn man sich in
diese Kanäle begibt dann muss man damit
auch leben was ich nicht mag ist eine
Haltung die in Deutschland dann doch
immer mal wieder rauskommt und
vielleicht noch mehr als in Bezug auf
China im Bezug auf die Ukraine die sagt
lasst uns damit irgendwie in Ruhe also
da wird auch die Angst
instrumentalisiert die Leute haben dann
Angst vorm Atomkrieg oder für irgendwen
schrecklichen Dingen die sind ja auch
alle schrecklich vor Putin muss man auch
Angst haben ganz richtig vor Putin Angst
zu haben aber die Größe die größeren
Grund für Angst den haben nun wirklich
gerade die Ukraine drin und Ukraine die
da vergewaltigt ermordet denn Kinder
verschleppt und deren Land kaputt
gemacht wird und dieses diese Mentalität
hier dann zu sagen lasst mich damit
lieber in Ruhe also macht lieber keine
auffänger das große Ganze
typische Haltung ist also er macht damit
ja auch krass also oder Kasse er macht
damit einschaltet
also ich muss ehrlich sagen mir hat er
aus dem Herzen gesprochen ich finde
wirklich
überforderte Außenministerin ist also
dass sie am Abend nicht gewachsen ist
und ich glaube nicht dass in Deutschland
gut vertritt weil ich meine ich bin auch
der Meinung dass wir bei China genau
hingucken müssen welche Art
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen wir machen weil
wir natürlich ein Rivalen haben der
bisher sehr geschickt ist verstanden hat
unsere Technologien zu holen sie im
eigenen Land einzusetzen und uns damit
am Ende Konkurrenz zu machen aber doch
manche aber nicht
nein ich meine nur ich habe ihr ja
zugestimmt was aus dem
Wirtschaftspolitik angeht aber ich finde
auf diese plumpe Art wie Frau bärburg
das macht kommen wir überhaupt nicht
weiter und sie ist auch unehrlich ich
meine diese Werte basierte Außenpolitik
der ganze globale südenacht sich tot
über die Werte basierte Außenpolitik des
Westens weil ich meine die diese Werte
haben eingeschlossen dass viele Kriege
geführt wurden auch Deutschland übrigens
hat ja eine sehr unmutige Geschichte
jetzt so weit zurückliegen aber trotzdem
in China ich meine wir haben dort
gewütet also dass der Boxeraufstand
wieder geschlagen wurde das waren
grauenvolle Verbrechen jetzt kommt die
deutsche Außenministerin und spielt sich
da als normal
die Chinesen haben es nicht vergessen
also ich glaube man sollte das zumindest
im Hinterkopf immer behalten
wie spricht man elegant mit einem
Diktator über Menschenrechte
was heißt elegant also weil sie sagten
es war plump oder es war es war ungelenk
also wie wie tut man unsere Haltung
deutlich machen aber diese Haltung also
es ist eine Doppelmoral weil wir sie
einfach bei einigen Ländern raushängen
lassen und bei anderen tun nichts
verschweigen wenn die einen was machen
finden wir das ganz schlimm dann gehen
wir zu dem nächsten Diktator habe ich
gleich ein paar Tage Frau merburg machen
großen glücklingen weil wir hoffen dass
wir dann Gas aus Katar bekommen so das
ist doch also das ist doch alles
Heuchelei und das finde ich ist das
Problem dieser sogenannten
wertebasierten Außenpolitik man hat
selber immer wieder während der
gebrochen man hat immer wieder
Völkerrecht aufgenommen
ist sie sitzen eine Partei der Erben der
SPD aber da kommen sie jetzt auch so
nein nein nicht lange Vergangenheit ich
bitte Sie Boxeraufstand war glaube ich
1900 wenn ich mir nicht täusche das was
ich meine hat hier vor 30 Jahren
stattgefunden ich habe auch gelitten ich
durfte nicht studieren
was weiß ich nicht war vielleicht habe
vielleicht also ja aber reden trotzdem
Unsinn ja wir mögen wissen sie leiden
veredelt die Menschen nicht das kann
eine viel Leiden trotzdem doof bleiben
das gibt es ja das habe ich aber nicht
ein Abrede gestellt
ich finde auch nicht dass wir die
DDR-Geschichte jetzt leugnen oder oder
auch das was
Unrecht statt bezeichnet es hat eine DDR
grobes Unrecht gegeben überhaupt keine
Frage aber ich glaube das ist keine
andere das ist jetzt eine Debatte die
uns nicht weiterführt weil wir dazu
betrachten weil ich habe in der DDR
Schwierigkeiten gehabt ich gehör nicht
zu denen die von der DDR profitiert
haben ich hoffe sie nicht studieren ich
hatte immer wieder Probleme und ich habe
am Ende überhaupt nur
schlecht gesagt dass beim Unrecht statt
ich finde was gegen Werbung spricht ist
einfach dass sie nicht nicht das
diplomatische Fingerspitzengefühl hat
was sie braucht sie sie
führt bei vielen Ländern und ich meine
wir merken das doch bei dir
Sanktionspolitik warum machen die
meisten Länder des globalen Südens bei
den Sanktionen nicht mit weil sie sagen
am besten ist unehrlich weil sie sagte
sind ehrlich
und die anderen Diktatoren dagegen sind
auch ehrlich also zumindest sehen
das ist der größte Teil der
Weltbevölkerung
das sind total übelste Diktaturen die
plötzlich die Moralen Decken
gleichzeitig mit ihnen sozusagen wir
wollen jetzt unsere Außenpolitik aus dem
Wirtschaftspolitik nur noch auf den
westlichen
Kernländer oder ich meine selbst bei der
Ukraine wer guckt denn da genau hin was
da im Vorfeld des Krieges schon in
Fragen Menschenrechten schief gelaufen
ist ich meine das ist ein Land da wurden
Fernsehsender verboten da wurden auch
ehrlich
über 20 Jahren sprechen und bei der
Ukraine ist ja auch viel passiert in den
letzten Jahren also wir reden jetzt
schon wir müssen ja schon sagen
nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion
also die die hatten alle ihren Weg zu
gehen
natürlich auch ein bisschen ja gut aber
sie sind eben grob das heißt sie sind
weil sie sich
endlich mal frei und sie verehren zum
Beispiel Leute wie manderer der analog
ich weiß dass sie mit Mandela an der
Stelle kommen
die Russen begehen verknüpfen historisch
und faktisch mit der Korruption den der
Ukraine wenn es doch doch verurteilen
nein sie haben selber gesagt ich muss da
nichts hinlegen
fertig wenn es um Korruption geht müssen
wir als erstes Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
Bomben weil Frau Schwesig sich extrem
korrupt Verhalten hat aber sowieso nicht
dass mein korrupte Länder mit Bomben
also wirklich also ich meine wie gesagt
ich finde diesen Krieg ein Verbrechen
ich finde nur die Einäugigkeit dann so
zu tun als er in der Ukraine alles in
Ordnung ja
Demokratie fährt naja im Moment ist da
gar nichts in Ordnung und und es ist
eine junge dynamische sozusagen
gesellschaftliche ganz Dollar am besten
drängte und wirklich nur so leben wollte
gerne so ungefähr frei und ähnlich wie
wir das hier tun und die Russen Bomben
die zurück ins Mittelalter und die
machen ihn jede Perspektive kaputt dafür
gibt's
auch weil sie immer immer peinliche
Veranstaltungen neulich in Berlin aber
sie haben schon selbst gemacht natürlich
war ich da mehr hat ein sehr gut
gefallen wie sie Frau warte das Mikrofon
umdrehen mussten weil sind das falsche
Ende gesprochen hat Highlight das ist
jetzt wirklich nicht ihr Niveau wir
bleiben
auch mal passieren oder wir bleiben
jetzt einmal bei der Sachlichkeit und
dann stelle ich mal eine Frage nachdem
ja Frau wagen sich die Fragen
beantwortet wie man diese Position haben
kann ist natürlich jetzt die die Frage
an sehr Bruder wie würden Sie denn zu
einem Ende des Krieges kommen also was
ist ihre Lösung wie weil dort sterben ja
viele diese Daten also worauf Ukrainisch
einfach russischer Seite wie würden sie
zwar am Ende kommen wirklich das wüsste
hätte ich längst darüber geschrieben und
es ist nicht meine Aufgabe mir darüber
Gedanken zu machen wie der Krieg beendet
werden könnte wir haben 16 Landtage für
ein Bundestag Bundesrat eine Unmenge von
Organisation Partei in Stiftungen Partei
Nano Organisation wir haben in Europa
hat den Europäischen Rat wir haben die
UNESCO warum soll ich es wissen ich weiß
nur eins dass ein Krieg diese Art ich
bin auch kein Pazifist und Kriege müssen
ab und zugeführt werden wenn die
Alliierten den Krieg gegen Nazis nicht
geführt hätten setzen wir nicht hier ich
zumindest nicht so aber in dem Falle
kann man die Fragen wie würden sie den
Krieg lösen natürlich kann man sagen
wenn der Westen auch für die Ukraine zu
bewaffnen ist der Krieg schnell vorbei
wenn man dem Opfer zur schnell nachgeben
dann hört die Aggression mal auf und das
kann nicht die Lösung sein nein ich
denke es muss eine viel stärkeren
Boykott gegenüber Russland geben
wirtschaftliche politische Maßnahmen
gestern
Sicherheitsrate gestern gesagt hat
irgendwas ähnliches wer war der
Vorsitzende der russische Außenminister
also ich meine eine schlimmere
moralische Demütigung für den Westen
kann es nicht geben und da und was was
die Russen jetzt machen ist genau das
genau das ist intervenieren sie nicht
gleich was die Nazis gemacht haben sie
erklären sich zu opfern für die Nazis
waren die Polen und die Juden die Opfer
die eine Art Deutschland angreifen
wollten und sie mussten
und die Ukraine macht das genauso und
Pudding ist dann schon Sie bitte putin
ist sowas wie Hitler ohne den Holocaust
und das macht die nicht weniger schlimm
und nicht weniger dass das tröst wurden
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie